what's up
everyone i'm finally in japan as you can
see
what kind of videos is he going to make
now that he's in japan
checking out convenience stores going to
different tourist spots trying out the
local
foods no
ready i am going to react to my sun
[Laughter]
leave your memes on the red at 19 year
olds and i'll measure your peeps in the
next
billboard for mark's new show looks
familiar
they just straight up ripped it off
i'll have to check that out it looks
like a really good poster at least if
the show is half or as good as the
poster i'll definitely watch it i
remember that photo shoot that was so
fun we did all kinds of crazy
i remember the camera guy kept going
like give me more of a scream face like
no no more like angrily
that's cool we got some great shots side
[Music]
i leave him
for a couple weeks and this is what
you've been up to
[Music]
you know what
i'm not even made
just disappointed
my mom sent me this that most famous
person
in sweden yay
that's me and oh it's not i just
realized there's not only good people on
this
i don't know i don't know if i want to
be group with some of these guys that
being chi okay i take it whenever you
land in stockholm they have all these
like names of awesome people like bjorn
borg is there i think notch is there
august strindberg
they're like welcome oh it's to their
hometown i guess that's fair i don't
live i'm i'm always like why am i not
here
i'm joking by the way yeah i don't live
in stockholm i live in motherfluff in
japan quick word from sponsor you know
japan is great and all and i love it
here they have amazing vending machines
at every corner with every drink in the
world at your exposed soul but you know
what they don't have a cereal sugar
energy drink with over 50 flavors
pewdiepie flavor yuzu flavor and now
the mega man flavor look at this beast
the mega man collector box it comes out
today on the 18th the flavor is called
blue bomber slushie and it tastes like
vanilla blue raspberry slushy i love
vanilla and i love raspberry they made
the shaker look like the mega buster
that's so cool i love that great
collector's item check out the link in
the description and if you use the code
pewdiepie i got you guys covered 30 off
on g fuel the greatest energy drink of
all time people say it's expensive use
the codes you definitely save money with
the codes support your favorite creator
link is in the description thank you g
phil for sponsoring this video now send
me my g fuel oh can i show you guys
actually this is not
yes i'm not wearing pants what are you
gonna do about it look
i still got my pewds collector box do
you guys still have yours this is this
is worth a billion one day at least i
sent this two years ago i haven't seen
this in so long
oh
yes
anyway let's go on with the video
flew private jet because my dog is too
fat world's richest all right
most subscribers also means more riches
uh youtuber pewdiepie relocates to japan
with his wife hugs my wife is pugs you
hear that guys
my wife is a pug i shouldn't be making
fun of bad english because i know i'm
butchering japanese every time i open my
mouth here i did say there was an
article in japan today
and all the comments are
not all of them actually some are quite
nice but a lot of them are like
super weird like
i second vote for six months when he
realized the heat and humidity are
higher than sweden
okay i guess i'll believe then he will
soon own all the youtubers here stay
tuned
that's right all jay youtubers jade
ligers i own you now
you're mine i suck you up
like a catamaran ball actually i roll
you on
you're all mine now yeah everyone thinks
i'm going to stay for six months and
it's lame this is a very
a very long and calculated decision okay
i know what i'm getting myself into i
know the summer's getting hot guys and
uh some people think i'm gonna be
worshipped because i'm caucasian okay
so as usual if you're rich you can still
buy your way in i i
applied in the exact same process as
everyone else did it does not say you
need to be rich to
to apply for a visa i don't know why so
some people thought we you can just like
pay your way in maybe you can i don't
know i didn't get to do that i would
have been i would enter a lot sooner
then but i did see on on like japanese
news people were really nice and they
were actually like explaining who i was
because i i think a lot of japanese
people don't know who i am and they were
they were explaining i could tell it was
you guys basically explaining my my
views and values and
yeah yeah i it was really welcoming from
japanese people actually and i really
appreciate that it feels really good i
want to be good to japan and i hope
japan can be good to me back and so far
it seems like it so i appreciate it what
is this that's my pp
huge huge pp i got foot pee pee i played
so much ellen ring i made grafting a
real thing maya is almost 17 years old
as well like we definitely got the jet
for her too
you want to say something
how does it feel to be the most spoiled
pug in the world
really getting my money money's worth of
content redesigning flags part 22. most
liked comment was sweden
[Music]
no it's perfect i always really like
sweden's flag i don't know if it's true
but i thought it represent the ocean and
the sun it's beautiful let's start by
adding three lines
flag
but i'm curious what they will do i'm
one of these [ __ ] that just cut to
the end of the video to see the result
we got the three crowns that's like an
old insignia of sweden i think pewds
would like this a lot yeah i like it i
just think flags should be simplistic
you know and this kind of breaks that
rule but it's really cool
i got the blue entrance
i got the blue as my dragon oh i could
get japanese cards here i sent like all
my stuff here two years ago right so
it's all here
all my books
my gundam
oh hell yeah my magikarps
yes
oh this deck is sick this is actually a
japanese card this deck is built around
this card it basically makes it so that
oh god it's all kanji i think this might
be chinese even no one cares about your
stupid cards feel like okay well trust
me it's cool if i play people with this
deck i i gotta be like trust me this is
what the card does okay
super strong card but it comes with a
hard cost of if you play it you can't
win the game and your opponent can't
lose so basically what you do is you
just bumping him up like [ __ ] crazy
because he got trampled and flying
you can buff him up with
flash right which makes him even
stronger and then you do right of
consumption and you sacrifice him which
basically makes that you sacrifice the
creature and the amount of power it has
it does damage it's literally just to
mana boom
boom
what was i doing tell her you're built
like pewdiepie but don't tell her which
pewdiepie oh yeah
i got my uh the gym setup i showed my
old gym
uh
it's garbage it's so bad
well here's my new one we come a long
way boys
we come a long way
oh hey hey there's a pen for you right
there
yeah i'm i'm gonna build the garage i
have the blueprint for it um i'll get my
gym for now honestly i don't care i i
can work out with whatever where girls
cried where boys cried were men cried
were bros
i cannot explain to you the amount of
relief that hit me at that moment i
think we made it seem so easy because
everything went well in in the video but
i kind of have a bit of disaster brain
where i constantly repeat that the worst
case scenario is gonna happen in my head
and the stakes were definitely high uh
trying to make this happen so yeah i was
i was dying on the inside basically
i never want to do that again i'm so
glad we took the private jet because we
made every oh let's get maya it made
everything so much easier moving to
japan soon trash tastes fun
dude it's never gonna happen these
[ __ ] i met connor and joey last
time i was in japan before the pandemic
and they were like we're gonna do a
podcast i'm like cool
i don't know if they actually asked if i
was gonna be on but kind of insinuating
yeah yeah well you wanna be a guest i'm
like sure absolutely pandemic happened i
can't come two years
finally i can go they're going to uk
while i'm here
oh happy channel anniversary
holy [ __ ] i missed it that's 12 years
12 years maya we got maya when she was
six
my toilet is cleaning itself i scared me
how they say yes in sweden i need for
the singaporean
that means yes
[Music]
and that means yes
yeah i think it's more in the northern
part of sweden but yes and it does tend
to leak over sometimes you should try it
it's a very comfortable way if you're
extremely lazy
and you don't even feel like saying yes
you just
give it a good slurp
i slept well i was already bored because
i wake up on
2016 pewdiepie
let's go
i was happy and i time traveled to good
old days hell yeah
it'd be fun to do an uh let's play maybe
on a different channel or something
because i kind of miss just like the
normal format like nowadays a new game
comes out everyone streams it
no one cares after like three days right
but back in the day it was like a new
game comes out 10 minute episodes take
it or leave it every single day i kind
of miss that though i feel like that was
a fun format i'm curious if that would
work on a different channel maybe i'm
not making any problem with this they
look so cute together we are cute
together okay oh finally cause i'm gonna
talk about the early ring video
number two
oh what you [ __ ] big
baby
dude i gotta thank you guys on all the
support in the elder ring video if you
guys haven't checked it out i recommend
it i definitely want to try and do more
stuff like that but i uh it will be
i don't know i don't know that was a
weird one i was like i really want to do
this i think it'll be fun and i really
appreciate all the support let me know
what kind of videos you guys want to see
in japan mine that a lot of the boys
are leaving now so i can't do many
collabs but yeah if there's anything you
guys wanted me to check out let me know
the biggest uh tourist point
in toronto canada did pewdiepie g fuel
shine
oh my god
so here they have uh obviously vending
machines you've heard about it they're
amazing i was thinking if there was a pv
uh not necessarily pewdiepie but a g
field vending machine would be that
oh that would be so good it's part of
the journey
say goodbye
it's not always easy
i'm happy it really means a lot that so
many of you guys care about us
in a way like i would say in a non-toxic
parasocial way like it's not no one's
being creepy no one's being weird it's
just like wishing good for each other
you know
yes big pee pee oh that's so sweet thank
you thank you for making growing up a
hell a lot easier that's so nice
i fly the private jet to flex my money i
flow in private jet because my dog is
stupid
first time that we thought we could go
and then pandemic happen
we actually dieted edgar it was a
healthy range but it was still kind of
pushing it and i just felt like
dude this is just mean i don't want to
make him do that again you can stay
fatigued it's okay people inspire me to
change my life here you're gonna have a
god i love you man oh [ __ ] hell
well done i don't know if that's even
real that's crazy
on that note
thank you guys for watching
i swear i'm in japan
i
appreciate all the support and i see you
guys in the next
video feast